the Sun is out and some of Britain has
locked down fatigue the Prime Minister
said he might make some changes to the
lockdown from Monday the danger now is
that many are not prepared to wait his
deputy formally extending the lockdown
this evening and urging restraint the
point at which we make even the smallest
of changes to the current guidance will
be a point of maximum risk if people
abandon the social distancing if we
forget the sacrifices that were made to
get us through the peak to get us to
this point the virus will grow again at
an exponential rate so we kept the
current measures in place for this long
precisely so that we can bounce back
with vigor and energy as soon as
possible as soon as is responsible to
start looking at the second phase the
Prime Minister said in the Commons
yesterday that there will be changes to
the lockdown from Monday a millions of
people would have read that that will
include more outdoor exercise and
sunbathing can you see how the public
will find this really confusing whatever
has been reported in the newspapers is
not a reliable guide to either the
evidence that we're getting or the
policy decisions that we'll be taking
and so that's why it's very important
that Prime Minister on Sunday will set
out a road map and I think it's safe to
say that any changes in the short term
will be modest small incremental and
very carefully monitored and as of now
there is no changes the leader of the
Opposition urging the public to stay at
home this weekend
well I think the government is right to
extend the lockdown we support them in
that that needs to be absolute clarity
that we must all follow the rules until
lockdown is lifted it doesn't mean we
can't discuss what comes next but we've
got to follow those rules the PM says he
wants to make some changes on Monday but
other national and regional leaders are
nervous I will not be pressured into
lifting restrictions prematurely before
I am as certain as I can be that we will
not be risking a resurgence of infection
rates I particularly strongly believe
that for us to drop the clear
well-understood stay-at-home message
right now could be a potentially
catastrophic mistake this is the
two weeks premature for us here in the
northwest as you said we are about two
weeks behind behind London and it
doesn't help anybody if we come out of
this too early in any region because if
the cases grow here again then they
won't pass to the Midlands and that will
ultimately come back to London another
weekend of lockdown the virus not beaten
yet we'll find out from the prime
minister on Sunday night what that road
mapped the new normal might look like
prepare for a long journey ahead bathra
B Sky News Westminster